well I think today's figure reflects the
political deadlock that we've seen right
until the general election that
political uncertainty that political
volatility has had an impact on growth
and investment the good news is since
the general election that deadlock has
ended we've ended the prospect of a
anti-business Marxist government we've
delivered our exit from the EU on a
smooth way and that means that we can
look forward with confidence but do you
think businesses have got the certainty
that they crave I mean a lot of
businesses we spoke to very recently say
they still don't know precisely what
kind of arrangement we're gonna have
after brexit so there is still more
uncertainty under your current plan well
it is true that we still need to know
exactly what the form of our free trade
agreement with Europe will be and the
Prime Minister just last week made a
speech on that setting out your what
we're after what we're working on with
our European friends and I'm confident
we will get an agreement but I do
understand from businesses that they
would like to know sooner rather than
later what form that takes but it is
also true that confidence is back we've
seen a surge in investment if you look
at confidence surveys by the leading
business groups just a couple of weeks
ago we had one for example from the CBI
when they surveyed manufacturers and it
showed the biggest surge in confidence
that we've seen a thinks in 60 years I
mean talking about those plans for after
we leave the EU yesterday the government
confirming that there will be import
controls on goods coming from the EU so
that implies friction on our trade
doesn't say we've been very clear we're
gonna have a different relationship with
the EU going forward it's still gonna be
a close relationship but for companies
that are trading with the EU they will
have to work out new processes in how to
do that business and that's why well it
will be it will be in the you know we
have about 250,000 businesses that
export only to the EU there many other
businesses that export to the rest of
the world those businesses are used to
working in with different processes and
what we're going to have to do when we
have a free trade agreement is to make
sure that every business is working with
government to minimize those but we also
need to think about the opportunities
that are created you know you're talking
about understanding
about the future trade with the EU which
remains important but we'll also be able
to strike with the freedoms that we have
your free trade agreements with other
countries across the world such as the
u.s. and Japan what's the economic
impact if this extra extra friction
going to be well well as we now agree
with the EU once we've got an agreement
and we bring it to Parliament of course
there'll be some kind of analysis that
goes along with it and that will be
there open and transparent for everyone
to see so you were doing analysis well
there there will be information that's
we're going to be provided your to
Parliament you know so it can you
properly scrutinize the deal but you
know when we take the the whole issues
your all of it together which is our new
relationship with the EU the freedoms
that we've got the plans that we have
for this country and such as the
infrastructure investments including
today's announcement about buses the
announcement about HS - the work that
we're doing on skills the plans that I
know that we're going to announce in our
budget you know this is a huge moment
for the country and it fills me with
confidence
just on that before we get to the budget
you know does it imply economic
sacrifices no it does it you know what
we what we really GDP won't be
negatively affected by the trade deal
and the brexit arrangements will I
believe in you once we've got agreement
it will be a comprehensive agreement
which will allow us to continue to trade
with our European friends and it also
allows us to do it also allows us to do
much more with many other countries and
also give us some freedom so just
yesterday give you another example we
announced our plans for a free port up
to ten free ports across the country
these enterprise zones will help to
create thousands or more jobs and these
are the kind of opportunities that we
can now exploit because we've exited the
European Union you talked about your
budget of coming up there are
constraints here you've got a fiscal
rule that you need to keep - that might
entail you know having to take some
difficult decisions when it comes to
taxes to try to meet that room Michael -
well it's absolutely right that we have
these fiscal rules because these ensure
that we keep public finances under
control but what it means is that every
time we think about your spending
more that we're going to have to think
very carefully about how we're going to
finance it and that is why we've been
clear for example with current spending
but also later this year we've got
what's called a comprehensive spending
review where we're gonna look again at
every pound that we spend to make sure
that nothing is wasted okay that might
well imply higher taxes if you need to
keep to that rule we're not planning on
higher taxes we're a low tax government
I want to keep I want to I want to keep
taxes as low as possible
I want to make taxes your simple I want
to be the government in a government
that was always a backing business but
ultimately the success of business do
that powers our economy that creates
jobs and that allows us to fund all
these fantastic public services what I'm
saying is I will keep taxes as low as
possible